hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to and
welcome to Star Trek mud engage review
yeah looking at say about Star Trek well
really everything it's a great vehicle
for creative ideas is an onslaught of
cliche right it's characters are
timeless and unforgettable their
personalities are on par with the Ninja
Turtles it's one of the greatest works
in sci-fi of all time it's the corniest
Sherlock you'll ever watch everybody has
an opinion on Star Trek
but there is one pattern that most
people seem to agree on when it comes to
the movie the even-numbered one seem to
be the best for whatever reason the
odd-numbered Star Trek films seem to be
the ones that get once-in-a-while
viewers and diehard fans really pissed
off I think we can't attribute that to
the binary structure it may 2000 or it
could just be a giant winsome David I
almost an image had an agenda so all
throughout January we're going to look
at the odd-numbered Star Trek movies the
ones that seem to get tricky panties in
a bundle and we're going to start off
with Star Trek the motion picture real
quick number one
energize I can't do take it as done
de perak Oh
[Music]
here we see our opening credits we get
William Shatner Leonard Nimoy before
it's Kelly and we then cut to some sort
of anomaly in space where the Klingons
come to check it out great job
wait a minute in the original show the
Klingons have flat head well now they're
all round and pointy what's up with that
okay tell me cameo picnic oh gee I was
hoping I could avoid this no choice I
have to face the music when I'm on
screen hi critic angry Joe oh thanks I
thought your only car up for a second
yeah I know he's obsessed with Star Trek
he's a total geek yeah tell me about it
so anyway I wanted to point out why
exactly the Klingons heads look like
that
you see there's actually several
different theories that's popped up over
the years the first one being that the
Klingons suffer from the neck Rock which
is a degenerative disease that only
their species suffers from yeah look uh
when I asked that question I was only
half curious when I even have a third
fifth the fans will kill me if I didn't
bring it up so you'll need to explain it
but surely you need a Star Trek expert
like me to help you through this no I
don't now when I could do that thing
where we go back and forth and then
suddenly I give in I'm doing it a lot
but credit you have no idea what you're
in for
come on it was directed by Robert Wise
one of the greatest directors of all
time I'm sure I can get through this
very well critic very well but do you
know the ancient Klingon proverb that
tells us revenge
no no longing was either justice off
Appa come on I don't wanted to do this
speech for years overdubbing audio great
hey y'all I am angry Georgia fastest
mouse in all Mexico I like to use in
screen because I'm a stupid hear they
like to drink everything Jordan I have
no friends only my elephant urine does
this incredibly racist accent Oh friend
you good I don't even think it's the
right nationality little t2 next time to
interrupt my review nicely done
now back to the review hey you know you
don't have to point every time you see
there
[Music]
so in typical Klingon fashion if they
don't know what something is they shoot
it oh yeah I should probably mention
this anomaly always seems to make what I
guess is supposed to be a disturbing
sound but it always sounds like a cord
off of an electric guitar excellent
Hey but the anomaly doesn't like that
and Fries them faster then I don't know
what she Balkan replacement for Spock
okay look what she Falk and replacement
for Spock you're both too you sir
it was my intention to be on that ship
following that meeting reported in one
hour
hmm I gave him two more lives before he
finally kicked the bucket Wow I hope you
paid that actor by the work he must have
been pissed and where is the real Spock
you may ask he's on the planet Vulcan
about the partake in a ceremony that'll
totally wipe out his emotions but he
senses the anomaly and finds he suddenly
can't go through it he's approached
Sochi mind-melds within and finds that
his brain is still filled with the most
illogical of human remains
in the middle of the earth in the land
of Charlotte's a brave little hobbit
when we all admire you though
Bilbo Baggins some leave me all so it
seems kirk is when we've been kept in
Decker of his duty for no other reason
then well he wants to do it I'm
replacing you as captain of the
enterprise
mask why my seminary with the enterprise
this is an almost totally new enterprise
you don't know we're a tenth as well as
I that's why you're staying aboard I'm
sorry
it told me how envious you were and how
much you hope you find a way to get a
starship command again it could be worse
you could be demoted to religious
propaganda on the WB a lot more bad news
Evans as it turns out the beaming of mr.
not Spock is going awry gee I wonder
what's going to happen to him yeah let
the captain who we've just been told
doesn't know 1/10 of the ship take away
control from the person who's been
trained specifically for this job
[Applause]
[Music]
enterprise when we got back to my mom
Marcin Utley
well good one Kirk you've been enjoyed
for only a hundred twenty seconds and
you've already caused two casualties
it's going to equal out to what a death
a minute and it's so weird scene two why
has this character all you're gonna do
is kill them off it's a grand waitress
scene like watching My Little Pony
adventure throwing in a horse exploding
I mean why do we need that
oh well battlefield promotion I'm afraid
you're gonna have a double as science
officer hey keep it up and maybe one day
you'll make activism we thank you the
only crew member to head was Herod
enchanter lieutenant Ilia hello i Leah
cake I was stationed on a lieutenants
home planet some years ago
commander Decker yes our exact and Saez
own Captain Kirk has the utmost
confidence in me and in you too
lieutenant
my oath of celibacy is on record captain
oh this close to spitting out my drinks
well as if this setup wasn't awkward
enough you really had to probe and get
their social skills lady my oath of
celibacy is on record captain anyway how
is your sex life
oh we still got one of us remember to
welcome aboard
both anything do you think all the other
people in this movie were dressed
ridiculously we need to get a load of
this getup
[Music]
well romanís Marty never returns in
something just a moment captain sir they
drafted me balls is a thing out there
why is any object we don't understand
always called a thing why can't it be
called a who this or a whatís so the
ship is all ready to go to stop the evil
anomaly before it reaches birth take a
shot a little faster than that please
yeah I just can't take another hour
isn't it
you're not 2001 a Space Odyssey okay the
Lord knows I look for the computer to
wipe out most of the crew is possible
I guess that was the action scene in the
middle of the picture I guess they
thought they needed a little bit more
excitement during this moment so they
threw in a guy nearly missing a door
well good to know you have your
thrilling tunnel a shot if you need it
Engineering's down by for warp drive we
need father watt simulation on the flow
sensors engineer we need warp speed now
it's borderline on the simulator captain
a kind of guarantee that you'll hold up
yeah fuck danger the captain what war
drive any was it now enter through the
opening of vertigo when suddenly they
realize what a shock
something's gone wrong small object has
been drilled into the world about
captain directly i order the whole
continue shaking the camera and a Greek
Photoshop smudge time to impact 20 taken
Empire phasers Oh sir wasn't reverse me
Adrian hold on
RINO's it turns out there's an asteroid
that's about to hit them in warp but
Dekker figures out how to save the day
so just to clarify kirsten inter only if
you alright then he's already killed two
crew members and nearly wiped out the
entire ship I follow this man to eternal
death mostly because I would have no
choice Scott we need warp drive sums
possible captain
it was a engine imbalance that created
the wormhole in the first place it will
happen together we don't correct it that
object is less than two days away from
Earth we need to intercept one it still
is out there holy shit you nearly killed
us moment not a few minutes ago
what why was my phaser order column
added sir the enterprise redesigned
increases phaser power by channeling it
through the main engines the phasers
were automatically cut off and you acted
properly of course captain Decker is
right I mean captain Decker I mean
captain Decker I mean he's look looking
captain I don't know why Kirk is there
I'm sorry if I embarrass you
just save the shit I'm aware of that sir
stop competing with me Decker
which means stop pointing we're not
obviously wrong well it turns out even
Decker can fall victims of certain
weaknesses like cheesy romantic past
dialogues what significance that is
difficult for you
[Music]
that you left Delta 4 didn't even say
goodbye
[Music]
if I had senior
would you open it
[Music]
[Applause]
what up kisser
and we get our last addition to the crew
mr. spot comes aboard to figure out why
he's been sensing the anomaly
I offer my services as science officer
if our exec has no objections of course
not so we now have a doubly demoted
Decker and Kirk is overjoyed because now
he can partake in all the various
over-the-top ways he can say Spock's
named Spock Spock Spock Spock fun spot
spot spot Stern's I've been saying it
wrong the whole time
it isn't Spock at this book but things
heat up when they finally come across
the evil anomaly oh my god viewer boo
bag sir
genuine friendship messages on all
frequencies because they figure out the
frequency in which to communicate the
anomaly lets them get closer and
eventually enter and yes
this results in slow slow
[Music]
veterans unrecognizable
god this is just watching a bunch of
footage and then seeing somebody comment
on it I want to see that
[Music]
oh Jesus it just keeps going do
something damn it
viral laser or some shit maybe if we
tried putting in a thrilling action
sequence nope please do something tell a
joke pull Spock ears off I don't care
just nothing cuz they'll even bother
with reactions anymore tickets are
showing longer and longer shots with no
friggin edits in them whatsoever guys s
top bang
oh my god the maggoty portal angry Joe
Wiggins you tell me tell me there's an
edit coming up these shots are going on
forever please give me a cuttin just
give me a try oh I've done far worse
than give you no cuts why aren't you and
I wish to go on parking you I so leave
you as this movie left me left all
audiences marooned in the center of a
dead screen
[Music]
[Applause]
but believe it or not something does
finally happen oh thank god milky
prostitutes a probe comes aboard and
starts taking control of the computer
well obviously spot will find the most
logical solution the hole he'll go
Neanderthal on its ass Spock's ah
Oh pop no likes a shiny thing it then
takes control by Leah and banishes her
into thin air
well she's there now tell me what she
celibate but she shows up later on the
ship having been taken over by the
anomaly Jim what's going on
tricorder no that's a bald woman but
this is a tricorder Jim this is a
mechanism tomorrow did you communicate
with the carbon-based units infesting
Enterprise I programmed to observe and
record Wow no emotions not feelings no
need it's the perfect woman
how so the anomaly is called Beecher and
it's searching for who or whatever
created her so that she may finally join
with it so while Decker shows her around
the ship allowing her to collect data
spots surprisingly steals one of the
space suits to see if he can communicate
further with veter computer commenced
recording Captain Kirk
these messages will detail my attempt to
contact the aliens so to put it lovely
he'll be back after these messages no
wait wait that's a joke that's a joke I
wasn't serious all right what are you
doing stop just a report we intercepted
by a word from our sponsor
damn it those advertising executives are
getting more and more clever raise our
shields against any more commercial plug
yes sir incidentally this raising of the
shield's is brought to you by the
delicious taste of diet coke jar sorry
sorry suppose journeys to the center of
be during comes across well there's no
subtle way to say it VG's vagina a V
journey if you will I mean yeah what is
that
I keep thinking I'm gonna have to put a
sensor bar over a thing first we got the
sky China in leghul ears and
we got that space China in Star Trek
there's almost that this side my writers
don't get a lot of pussy but that'd be
ridiculous just look at this last
picture of Phil decay dick who man whore
I've tried to mind-meld would be drew
but gets his ass handed he returns to
the ship to report that feature came
from a planet populated by living
machines and has evolved with incredible
knowledge all except for one question
who the Creator is and read your vows to
cure the universe of carbon unit mostly
the ones on earth until she finds her
answer the carbon unit infestation is to
be removed from the creator's planet
Beecher is a child evolving learning
searching I suggest you treat her as
such hey does Vito wanna go to Chuck E
Cheese this video want to see a Justin
Bieber concert does Vedra want to fund a
franchise about a sparkly vampire that
setting women back dozen 30 years the
carbon units know why the Creator has
not responded disclose the information
not until VJ withdraw the device's
orbiting the third planet so perp says
he'll give the information but only to
the center of Beecher herself the probe
complies and Kirk plans his next move
Scotty prepare to execute start the
order to survive captain ordered
self-destruct I would say last because
he thinks he votes like when we go up
who take the intruder with it hahaha I
signed up for Starfleet to pay for my
college is there any chance we can not
blow up on my very first mission so how
powerful is the emotional need at the
center of Beecher well apparently it's
so powerful it moves folklore dr. oz
so captain the future
with the Bleacher as I would remember
the brother that we find out you have
later and clearly did not wait for but
the one will be at a time so they get to
the center of Beecher and find out that
Beecher is in fact Voyager Voyager six
the satellite that was sent out years
ago and got sucked into a wormhole
landing it on the machine planet it
evolved over the years and now it wishes
to still somehow join with its creator
you mean this machine wants to
physically join with the human is that
possible let's find out
Decker I'm gonna keep the final sequence
through the ground test computer so
whatever he just says apparently means
that Decker is giving himself to the
computer so they're joining sets off a
giant explosion and enterprise gets the
hell out of there did we just see the
beginning of the new my phone yes
captain
witnessed a birth possibly a next step
in our evolution
well let's never reference this big step
in evolution again and anything
startling that way it'll show just what
it impacted add on our evolution Julie
this is a big day
battling till the true is back informed
they're happy a Big Bang was set up by a
Big Bang and they go off to where no man
has gone people
and that was the first Star Trek movie
and let me tell you I can see why it's
often called the slow motion picture the
ideas are interesting even provocative
but most of the characters aren't
developed in an interesting way the
painting and unbelievably slow and on
top of that is so boring the effect
elements are very impressive but when
you have to look at them for what feels
like an eternity you get sick of them
pretty fast I really feel like this film
was trying to do what 2001 a Space
Odyssey you know sort of make it like an
experience but that's not what Star Trek
was mostly about it was more about a mix
of ideas and characters not as much an
out-of-body experience and the
out-of-body experience this movie can
conjure is taking us a fucking dreamland
so take it for what it's worth I'm gonna
tell your critic in Star Trek Muppets on
the way
[Music]
my oath of celibacy is on record